what's up guys bangbang lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just try to get a lunch money
right I'm here with the beautiful
intelligent plain Tamara Nova she's got
on that stupid Georgia yeah sure stop
talking well listen don't wear dumb
things go Gators
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by black 5 3 products buy and
sell crypto deposit crypto or stable
coin and receive a u.s. dollar loan or
you can deposit crypto or stable corner
of the 8.6% a py bought by calm slash
lunch money
go check them out get money get paid
what's up so happy 4th of July everyone
in the u.s. July 3rd I know but you
could still say cuz the weekend it's a
holiday weekend actually yes
July 3rd ok jobs happy 4th of July
everyone
go ahead what's going on jobs employers
added a record 4.8 million jobs last
month as the economy continued to slowly
bounce back from a deep and painful
coronavirus recession this is a little
misleading because this number is
outdated as now some states are seeing
an increase in cases so it may bounce
back again not bounce back bounce
whatever I'll believe none of the
numbers lie I don't believe the
unemployment numbers I don't believe
that adding jobs back numbers none of
this stuff and watching the week to week
numbers is I think directionally can
give you some idea there probably was
some jobs added back but at the same
time they go back and they readjust
these numbers sometimes they've
literally readjusted by hundreds of
thousands or millions depending on on
the size of it and so it's just a thing
where look we know that the economy is
reopening obviously if companies fire
people and now they're reopening there
have to bring some people back that's
great but there are still a massive net
loss of jobs in the United States for
hovering somewhere in the 12 to 14
percent unemployment rate and that's the
official number so the unofficial number
we're probably closer to 20 percent if
not more and my general sense is that
we're going to stay above 10 percent
unemployment for
for a considerable future because most
of these small businesses aren't coming
back so you don't believe Trump when he
said our economy is roaring back it's
coming back extremely strong are you
spending more money uh it's been a good
amount of money online
yeah but restaurants are open you look
in New York City right now is it opening
yeah of course so of course isn't
economic activity but we're nowhere near
where we were pre-pandemic
it's like this whole idea of like oh we
bounced off the bottom okay great
all I care about is how long does it
take to get back to just where we were
and then we can get growth all of this
kind of like oh you know there's a 50%
growth it's like when a start-up pitches
us and they're like oh we've grown 300
percent month-over-month and you're like
okay just say tripled or just okay we
tripled month-over-month
great how many users did you like oh we
start out with 10 it's like all right so
you got 30 years congratulations that's
great but I don't care because you're
growing from such a small number that it
should be way bigger than growth
same thing here is like literally
remember the movie industry perfect
example 200 million dollars in revenue
in a single week in the u.s. box office
in March of 2019 in 2020 they did $5,000
so for them to go from five thousand
dollars to a million dollars yeah you
can sit there and celebrate oh look at
this huge percentage increase but you're
still doing 99 percent less than you
were doing before it doesn't really
matter right yeah as a reporter a lot of
founders used to be like oh I can't
share revenue but I can tell you we grew
a hundred percent year-over-year and I'm
like that literally tells me absolutely
nothing you could have had $10 like
exactly what's one of lemonade lemonade
was lemonade yesterday price that's
initial public offering at $29 a share
and wound up soaring nearly a hundred
and forty percent to finish Thursday
above $69 the company raised nearly 320
million from the stock sale okay so this
is a possum up on some positive news for
a company going public in 2020 know why
this is a crime why this is literally
criminal type stuff not actually just so
before people forget it's not actually a
crime but here's what ends up happening
I wrote about it today about the IPO
process being broken
there's people way smarter than me
they've been talking about this way
longer so these are necessarily aren't
original thoughts but the whole idea is
as a company you're selling shares to
raise capital and so what you end up
doing is they sort of for $29 a share
but when it goes in more than doubles
that means they left a bunch of money on
the table so what they ended up doing is
I think they raised around 300 million
dollars but if they had priced the IPO
correctly where it ended up trading then
they would have raised over 700 million
dollars right so they left on the dip no
it's not the difference is a four
hundred and almost fifty million dollar
difference they only had about five
hundred and forty million dollars on
their balance sheet already so they
would have nearly doubled their balance
sheet capital just with the difference
between where they price the IPO and
where it actually traded the what ends
up happening is that investment bankers
and their clients or financially
incentivized to buy the stock at the IPO
price as low as possible the company is
incentivized to buy it at the highest
price possible or to sell at the highest
price possible but the investment
bankers have all the power because they
do this every single bet right they're
like this is their job the founders
probably take a company public one time
and so the power structures off so ends
up happening is the trishal IPO process
gonna go away people gonna do direct
listings you're gonna do a reverse
takeovers like they're just gonna get
out of this game where yesterday there
literally was a four hundred and fifty
million dollar mistake in the market
four hundred fifty million dollars
lemonade made a mistake
they didn't price the IPO correctly I
don't know it's just so hard to know
because if they miss price that then in
in the other direction
he'd be like oh they would be good for
the company no that's the whole thing if
they priced it too high they would raise
money and then the stock price would
drop but they still would get the
capital if you're gonna miss miss by
pricing it too high rather than to love
I don't know just do a direct listing
direct listing solves all this so does
reverse take oh okay ready yeah what's
going on thisis Jeff Bezos
thanks to Amazon stock price yesterday
he set his wealth set a new record he's
worth nearly a hundred seventy two
billion the richest person in the world
and that's because he owns roughly
57 million shares or 12% of Amazon just
so we're clear he's the richest man in
the world and he still gave his ex-wife
30 billion dollars think about that your
second she took 25 percent of his Amazon
stock about 30 billion dollars at the
time if I remember correctly and so even
though he lost 25 percent of his wealth
and gave his ex-wife 30 billion dollars
he still got 170 billion which means
that he hadn't done that he'd have 200
billion dollars okay do my ball one
she's now she also set a new record
she's now worth fifty seven billion
making her the 12th or richest person in
the world that's huge
her wealth is up 54 percent year-to-date
over the last two years it's up about 50
billion dollars she's not selling of
course not
why would she sell was she gonna sell at
all I'd be like you want to divorce me
I'm selling all yo [ __ ] including my
shirt but he may know more the best
founders in the world the best companies
like it's gonna keep growing I don't
care if you do that a spite yeah well
that would have been a twenty seven
billion dollar mistake I don't care
I don't need your blood money is it
blood money yes I use Amazon money
I think it's blood money okay pizzas
know what involved no oh my god this is
saying devolved quickly pizza hype so
NPC international the largest Pizza Hut
franchisee in the United States and an
operator of almost 400 Wendy's locations
filed for bankruptcy yesterday wow you
got we got Chuckie Cheese we got Pizza
Hut we got what was the other one that
file for bankruptcy a bunch oh look I'm
the girl the virus no the front of our
thing definitely helps but this company
has like billion dollars in debt they've
a billion dollars in debt what are you
doing getting a billion dollars in debt
here's the problem
debt is good until it's not it helps you
grow it's awesome whatever all the
positive aspects of being able to use
leverage Jimmy screeches to a halt in
your leg you get rekt that's what
happened they got rekt they had a
billion dollars in dead coronavirus
before summers shut down their stores
cash flow dried up right and they
claimed that food costs are rising like
get a deer that's not
to do with you going bankrupt the
Faculty of a billion dollars in debt in
your cash flow got shut off and so what
they could have done I'm assuming they
tribe and do is go find equity or debt
investors to invest to try to refinance
or get about that of course that's what
you have to do or you or you file for
bankruptcy like these guys did I mean
it's basically your options sorry I'm
just I don't know it like you're you're
a little tiring oh my god all right
don't get a billion dollars of debt and
have your cash flow shut off and you
won't follow these people well I mean
it's the Pizza Hut no room Pizza Hut
isn't filing for PC it's one it's a
company that owns franchises of Pizza
Hut and Wendy's have what other places
yeah you're bad don't worry I may be
tiring but I read the internet I'm smart
are you saying I'm not sorry I didn't
say that I just said that you didn't
understand the nuances of this situation
and therefore I wanted to help explain
it to you some might call that mansplain
or somebody's called explain either way
that's fine what's going on the baby
incubator that's my favorite story but
he made me so basically some player is
they have I think they have developed it
I don't think it's actually working but
a baby incubator that allows you to grow
a baby outside of the womb it's
basically an artificial artificial womb
but my favorite part about this is that
it looks super space AG level of Jetson
style it sits over in the corner on a
stand and they think that you're gonna
put like the fetus in the artificial
womb and then literally in there like
marketing video they have a cord that
runs to a guy's desk and he's got a
microphone and it's like you can speak
to the fetus and he's sitting there and
he's like talking into it and then it
literally is a microphone into the thing
it's kind of crazy but like do you think
that this is gonna be in the future yes
I actually do I talk I talk to you know
I listen to a podcast episode with Tim
urban who writes wait but why and he
said that his biggest prediction is that
in the future pregnancy is gonna be a
of the past like something only the
hippies do like who the hell is actually
using their body to because it's really
I mean it's it's tough on your body
and it's like it's the the future and
the modern people are gonna be like oh I
just grow my baby outside of myself and
then the people who are like super
hipster and whatever they're doing a
natural pregnancy so I I think that
that's I think that I think that we'll
have to have a little alien babies
running around little alien babies
they're not alien babies they're just
you know they were grown in their lab
grown babies they're like the beyond me
of yes like a lab grown baby yeah masks
pretty dope is long as it's saving right
obviously good news because you don't
have to give birth like you you know Kim
Kardashian guys don't have to deal with
morning sickness for with their wives
and stuff just saying Kim Kardashian
would love this okay
well and by the way I just want to you
three yeah the surrogate is basically
like the original artificial womb no it
is it's a real womb it's just somebody
else's I understand but that's like an
artificial womb basically it's because
like the woman doesn't want to have the
kids they get somebody else to do it but
basically what's interesting getting
somebody else do it versus using the
artificial womb they're both artificial
to the woman okay
just saying Carol Baskin you think the
kids would have issues growing in the
lab I see okay here's what I think
just imagine rappers in like 40 years
gonna be like dad that's right I was
born in the lab they cook they cook me
up in the lab but I will say I think so
what they say is like for example when
you do a surrogate pregnancy somebody
else has having the baby that person
because they're going through that
process they bond with the child a lot
and I think sometimes it's like hard for
the surrogate to give the baby away etc
even though he's a minion fact checks
they're getting so what I'm saying is I
think that the growing babies and labs
might actually not have the same
connection between the mother and the
child how much do you think a surrogates
surrogate I do not know over under
$25,000 probably more you think so yes
Dan hey you're putting me again
get cash that way I can't do it I was
cooked in the lab okay what's going on
with Carol basket Carol [ __ ] Baskin
for a hundred and $69 you can now get
Carol Baskin to give you or your friend
a shout-out on cameo her bio says you
know me as Tiger king Joe exotics
intended murderer victim but my real
life's work has been a big cat rescue
for a world where all wild cats live
free please be a voice for cats big cat
act calm she's a fraud she forgot she
forgot she's a fraud hello you cool cats
and kittens she's a fraud why she
doesn't have anything about wild cats
being free she literally has animals in
cages cat rescue is no different than
the original zoo that Joe exotic had why
should only charging $169 also it's very
specific about one hundred and sixty
nine dollars why don't you just charge
like a thousand dollars for this your
Carole [ __ ] Baskin cuz no one's gonna
pay a thousand dollars Baskin doesn't
matter if she does know it does she does
it was cool but Carole Baskins 15
minutes of fame is rodeo I don't think
it's over nobody cares come has she done
she's done what three no okay so she's
probably made $1,000 on here good for
Carole bad I think she's I still think
she murdered her husband that's my
personal will you stop look at her hair
saying okay what's going on with lunch
money what do you want people to do
today oh we didn't fascinate 15 minutes
all right lunch money what do you want
people oh oh okay
this is gonna be not smart maybe my
favorite joke or your favorite joke your
favorite joke with a link to lunch money
tweet so you have to tell them how to do
it you have to say take the URL go tweet
a link to the URL use hashtag lunch
money and include your favorite joke of
cleanness this we do know your favorite
joke oh oh your favorite joke tell us
your favorite joke and the funniest one
will get a hundred dollars for lunch
perfect hundred bucks you can go get
dinner with your friends extra points if
the joke involves can buy drugs you can
do whatever you want with the money we
don't care what you do not buy drugs
okay well she doesn't want you to buy a
drug that me personally I think
we should decriminalize all drugs but
that's fine oh my god all right what
else anything oh my joke what's your
joke no mad at you and say I'm funny
fine
why don't scientists trust atoms why
don't sigh insist trust atoms because
they always split up no because like you
they make everything up no it's because
they make up everything exactly why
don't scientists trust ABS because they
make up everything yeah you had better I
[Music]
got my one brother here if you guys want
to meet him he looks he looks real cool
he's got a moustache look at him go he's
got that moustache looking like a
version of either Tom Selleck or who
else maybe who's the guy in chips with
the aviators who rides the motorcycle
for the California Highway Patrol Erik
Estrada I think it is look at my gum mix
between Tom Selleck and Erik Estrada
he thinks he looks like Groucho Marx I
think he might look like something else
I ain't gonna say it though thank you
okay all right that's it guys that's it
for lunch money this week well while
she's trying to get rich Russell was
just trying to get a lunch money right
hopefully Polina makes it back next week
after she's annoyed and I just called
out Carole Basking because it was Carole
[ __ ] Baskin see you bang-bang hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of lunch
money as much as we did don't forget
lunch money is now sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
I'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fire
than you are of me block wise my second
favorite thing in the world behind
Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associate
but 8.6% it's pretty compelling so click
on the link in the description say
thanks to the folks that block by
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy plan in the comment and we'll see
you guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends